الأوقات العصيبة تتطلب اتخاذ
إجراءات يائسة، وفي غزة يعني ذلك نهب
المخبز المحلي الذي دمرته
غارة جوية إسرائيلية بين عشية وضحاها، فليكن
مخبز باقة باكا كلمة عربية
تعني مباركة ولكن غزة الآن تحت
لعنة الحرب، لقد كان آخر
مخبز عامل  في دار
بيلا، ضرب الاحتياجات الأساسية للناس
هو نوع من
الإرهاب بمجرد شروق الشمس. يوم الاثنين،
نزل الناس من جميع الأعمار إلى
المخبز وأخذوا أكياس
الدقيق
وزيت الطهي وبقايا الخشب لاستخدامها في الطهي
والتدفئة وأي شيء آخر
يمكنهم القيام به.
حمل هذا الرجل يصفه بكلمة واحدة،
برامج الغذاء العالمية تحذر عبيرا
سكان غزة من الوصول إلى
نقطة الانهيار عندما ينهار النظام المدني
تمامًا لأن الناس
أصبحوا يائسين، قفز، يائسين،
جائعين بحلول اللحظة التي يكون هذا بالطبع
أه ملزمًا به
ومع أن القوات البرية الإسرائيلية
تعمل الآن في جنوب غزة، فإن
مئات الآلاف الذين فروا من
الشمال بحثًا عن الأمان أصبحوا الآن
أكثر من أي وقت مضى في خط
النار في غزة بعد ما يقرب من شهرين من الحرب.